hello everyone my name is researcher
Miller and the SCP we are going to be
studying today is SCP nine
with procedures subject is to be
contained within a sealed storage tank
of heat-resistant alloy with dimensions
not less than 14 meter cubed under no
circumstances should a cp9 be exposed to
temperatures in excess of zero degrees
when not undergoing testing no mundane
liquids in a solid state shall be
allowed within 30 meters of the subjects
containment area subjects chamber is to
be fitted with temperature sensors which
shall be monitored at all times and is
to be kept refrigerated by no fewer than
three redundant cooling units an email
function of sensors or of coolant
systems is to be reported and repaired
immediately if at any time the
temperature in the containment area
climbs above -5 degrees the chamber is
to be locked down immediately and
flooded with coolant until the
temperature has been brought back down
between minus 30 and minus 25 atmosphere
must be evacuated from the containment
area when personnel are present with it
and any water vapor present must be
filtered and kept in the same conditions
as detailed herein for no fewer than 24
hours any vapor displaying properties of
SCP 9 is to be quarantined and added to
the containment area as soon as possible
all personnel interacting with or
observing the subject must wear full
environmental protection suits all
personnel leaving the containment
chamber must undergo dehydration of all
gear research materials and other
objects contacting si p 9s
if contamination is discovered no
materials or personnel shall be
permitted to exit and a level 2 lockdown
of the containment area shall commence
lethal force is authorized in cases of
dire need but all security forces are
strongly advised to remain as far away
they're targets as possible to minimize
the chance of contact with fluids
contaminated by SCP 9 description SCP 9
is approximately 3,700 litres of a
substance which exhibits a number of
unique properties while small amounts of
the substance in all phases are as
colorless as mundane water on mass it
takes on a distinct deep red hue its
most notable property however is the
fact that scp-966 actly opposite that of
standard h2o the subject assumes a
liquid phase at temperatures between
minus 100 and 0 degrees and converts
into a solid state above those
temperatures at temperatures below minus
100 degrees as CP 9 v p-- Rises into a
gaseous phase similar to steam though it
still retains its red coloration when
put under high pressure examinations of
the atomic structure of SCP nine
indicate that the subject is composed of
the same combination of hydrogen and
oxygen as normal water leaving
researchers to speculate that the source
of the subjects abnormalities may be the
atoms themselves dr. Poole has suggested
that the subject may have originated in
or been altered by another reality in
which laws of physics are inverted this
theory may have some merit in light of
se p 9s marked ability to assimilate
natural water into its mass if placed in
physical contact with any equus solution
be it ice salt water or water vapour in
air scp-989 said solution causing it to
exhibit the subjects properties though
this capacity is present in all phases
it has been observed to progress most
slowly
thus be most containable in the liquid
phase if the subject comes in contact
with any biological source of heat it
begins a runaway reaction in which the
organisms bodily fluids are rapidly
converted to SCP 9 and promptly frozen
by their own body heat because of their
generally high core temperatures mammals
are particularly susceptible because as
CP 9 produces heat while freezing at the
same rate mundane ice consumes he while
melting the process is self-perpetuating
until all available moisture is
converted or until it is halted by an
external interference experiments on
Class D personnel have illustrated the
process of conversion by the subject
which has been condensed down to a
series of steps one initial exposure
subject is exposed to SCP 9
converting any water present on the
exposed surface usually skin to exhibit
its properties presence of mist fog snow
or other solid vaporous water greatly
accelerates this process number two
surface conversion a thin layer of frost
forms on the exposed area as body heat
and heat produced by a cp9 raise its
temperature above freezing progression
to this step can take anywhere from five
minutes to one hour depending on the
victim's body temperature at this stage
freezing has begun progressing through
the initial layers of the epidermis and
soon reaches live cells number three
deep tissue conversion exponential
increase in temperature of scp-906
panshin of ice crystals throughout the
victim's body resulting in widespread
perforation of internal cell structure
actual blood loss is minimal at this
stage due to crystals filling the
puncture wounds allowing subjects to
remain alive and conscious for up to
hours
number four number five death multiple
organ failure and exsanguination via
systemic crystallization testing on
d-class personnel was discontinued as of
the 23rd of April 2000 addendum
circumstances our retrieval subject was
found at Alaska on the 5th of November
19 the foundation became involved after
reports were obtained from the native
tribe who came across the mangled bodies
of a team of seal hunters who had
apparently been shipwrecked kilometers
from the village all victims found were
encased in red ice cause of death
recorded as internal bleeding on victims
whose features were sufficiently intact
expressions of panic and intense pain
were observed it is surmised that the
low ambient temperatures in the area
[ __ ] the freezing process this
prolonged the time to total conversion
month hours and allowed victims to
remain conscious until addendum the 16th
of December to supper cooling of scp-914
is disallowed until further notice
personnel are advised that liquid
nitrogen is only to be used on the
subject in controlled amounts and only
until temperatures have reached
acceptable levels related no possible
application of SC p 9n cold fusion
research pending evaluation and that
about does it today thank you very much
for listening everyone you were
dismissed thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you